id musique après les revenants des
années 60 et 70
voici le retour des groupes des années
80 la grand v la grande époque de la new
wave
vous vous souvenez sans doute de depeche
mode et bien ils font salle comble au
libellé nous à dominique bonnet dès la
première chanson la machine électro des
des choix des lancers
car tout en europe comme ici à marseille
les places de penseurs se sont arrachés
6 mois al avance le public de depeche
mode est présent depuis depuis très
jeune plus mon âge est ce qui a fait
dire ta maman c'est plutôt de la
lui-même toujours un tabou
m
à paris se produiront quatre soirs à
bercy une revanche pour un groupe que
certains jugeaient démodé d'une façon
générale nous sommes un groupe
pessimiste nous avons tendance à ne voir
que les côtés négatifs des choses alors
nous avons été surpris de voir que tous
nos concerts on était complet si vite
les sourires la sérénité de trois
anglais de 40 ans revenu de loin à leurs
débuts en 1980 les moqueurs ne voient en
eux que des garçons coiffeurs
ils s'en moquent son sacré roi de la pop
électro
les tubes s'enchaînent
dix années de triomphe puis la descente
aux enfers crise personnelle ego
démesuré drogue il même une tentative de
suicide pour le chanteur dave gahan
je suis un vrai survivants je suis juste
mon chemin ces dernières années j'ai
beaucoup appris sur moi
après des années d'errance depeche mode
vient de signer un 11e album salué par
la critique
intitulée playing the angel jouer à
l'ange logique pour un groupe qui a
côtoyé les démons et qui aujourd'hui a
retrouvé la foi